bonjour merci de prendre le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
on a du mal à comprendre comment un tel
piratage est possible expliqué nous
alors avec une technique qui est assez
simple au final qui consiste à
s'attaquer non pas la technologie mais à
l'être humain qui opère la technologie
visiblement certains employés de chez
twitter ont été abusés ou ont été
complices la mairie de l'ira mais il ne
s'agit pas d'une prouesse technologique
qui a permis à des hackers de se rendre
maître de twitter wallah on n'est
absolument pas dans la prouesse
technologique et qui plus est les
conséquences sont pour l'instant très
très limité
alors comment réagit à twitter piratage
quelles procédures ont été mises en
place il est beaucoup trop tôt pour le
savoir mais très pas seulement des
procédures qui vont permettre de ne pas
refaire la même chose une fois de plus
il ya visiblement un outil qui est
interne à twitter qui a été dispersé
dans la nature donc j'imagine qu'ils
vont revoir cet outil peut être repenser
complètement leur procédure qui les ont
amenés à avoir un tel outil mais on ne
peut leur faire confiance de toute façon
ils vont tirer les conséquences de ce
hack une arnaque de quelques cent seize
mille dollars ça me semble pas si énorme
et ce que les internautes en grande
majorité ont flairé l'arnaqué
ou bien est-ce que ces robots twitter a
simplement réagi suffisamment vite dit
verdi l'autre il s'agit tout simplement
d'un coup lamentable en termes de
cybercriminalité c'est un peu comme si
on avait fait un casse dans une énorme
bang et qu'on s'était contenté de
récupérer 3 3 friandises et de carambar
très concrètement si on a le contrôle de
compte aussi important on peut semer par
exemple un chaos boursier on peut même
imaginer commencé à voir une escalade
entre pays parce que visiblement il
aurait tout aussi bien pu prendre le
contrôle de du comte de donald trump
donc les conséquences de ce hack aurait
pu être cataclysmique qu'attaquer
séquelles déjà quelques années
des hackers s'était rendu maître du seul
compte de bloomberg avait tweeté à
propos d'une attaque présupposés
terroristes à la maison blanche et le
dow jones avait décroché de plusieurs
points des cybercriminels d'euros vol
aurait parfaitement pu spéculer à la
baisse des cours de bourse et jouer la
bourse avec
une telle un tel contrôle de compte
aussi important donc vraiment on s'en
sort très très bien on s'aperçoit que ce
type d'arnaqué est très courant sur
twitter vous le rappeler à l'instant le
compte de la nouvelle par exemple avait
déjà été signés pour détourner des
bitcoins est ce qu'on la remarque sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est
institutionnalisé elle est à la portée
de tout le monde aujourd'hui
larnack s'est internationalisé avec les
réseaux sociaux il ya même certains pays
qui ont fait une culture mais au final
c'est une pratique qui est vieille comme
le monde les on double arnaque n'a pas
attendu les réseaux sociaux pour exister
à tout les échelles de la société du
tout en bas jusqu'au plus haut il n'y a
rien de nouveau fondamentalement si ce
n'est un outil supplémentaire on faisait
des arnaques en envoyant des courriers
et 7 ce type d'arnaqué la nappe actuelle
faisable avant la poste et avant la
poste il y avait d'autres formes d'art
d'accès bioko le monde alors comment est
ce qu'on fait pour se prévenir de telles
attaques est ce qu'il existe une
sécurité un viol à vous alors est ce
qu'il va falloir apprendre à vivre avec
la possibilité d'un vol de ces données
personnelles la sécurité un viol at ça
n'existe pas la sécurité à 100% ça
n'existe pas c'est un concept théorique
vers lequel on doit attendre mais on ne
peut pas sécuriser quoi que ce soit à
100% c'est absolument impossible qui
épuisé il ya en face choix des failles
béantes
visiblement il y avait une faille donc
l'organisation humaine de twitter mais
même dans les technologies les plus
sécurisés de la planète il ya
systématiquement des pales ça n'est
qu'une question de rapport de force
entre les assaillants et ceux qui
tentent de protéger une technologie et
puis aussi un capteur chance mais
vraiment j'insiste là dessus ça n'existe
pas la sécurité à 100%
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions fabrice epelboin je rappelle
que vous êtes enseignant à sciences po
paris et spécialiste des réseaux sociaux